wir wollen noch mal zu unserem Kollegen
Philipp piatov Schalten der in Lemberg
ist das ist ganz im Westen der Ukraine
also ziemlich weit weg von den
schrecklichen Bildern die wir gerade
auch bei Paul ronsheimer gesehen haben
Philipp wie ist die Situation momentan
bei dir beschreib mal so ein bisschen
den Alltag dort geht's dort ganz normal
weiter oder haben die Menschen auch dort
Angst obwohl das ganze spielt sich
hunderte Kilometer weit weg ab
ja die Lemberger machen einfach weiter
mit ihrem Leben sie haben ja auch keine
andere Wahl aber was ich vielleicht von
den anderen Tagen unterscheidet ist dass
sie alle paar Minuten natürlich sehr
nervös aufs Handy schauen ich saß vorhin
im Taxi als die Eilmeldung kam das
labroff der russische Außenminister
plötzlich gesagt hat dass die Ukraine
keine Recht auf ihre Souveränität
Souveränität hat da ist im Taxifahrer
fast übel geworden weil das hört sich
natürlich nach Kriegsdrohung an und seit
gestern wird wirklich massiv eskaliert
man hört und immer mehr Menschen die
auch aus Kiel nach Lemberg kommen weil
es hier sicherer ist die Amerikaner
haben ja sogar die ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski empfohlen hierhin
nach Lemberg zu kommen weil das eben
wenige Kilometer von der polnischen
Grenze weg ist aber in Lemberg ist noch
nicht zu spüren von der Eskalation der
geht alles vorerst deinen normalen Gang
Olaf Scholz hat sich in einer
Pressekonferenz gerade auch bei den
Ukrainern insbesondere bei Präsident
selensky bedankt dass man auf
Provokationen nicht eingeht und er sagte
dann wörtlich Putin wartet nur auf einen
Vorwand möglicherweise die gesamte
Ukraine zu besetzen in der Tat also auch
die deutsche Bundesregierung schließt
dieses Szenario nicht aus
ja ehrlich gesagt dass die Ukraine nicht
auf Provokationen antworten soll das ist
ja nur ein Zeichen der Schwäche und die
Ukraine weiß natürlich dass sie alleine
nicht gegen Russland ankommt aber die
Unterstützung aus dem besten ist bislang
in ihrer Aktivität einfach
zurückgeblieben man hat Deutschland hat
nicht mal geschafft Helme zu schicken
deswegen du keine hat ja gar keine
andere Wahl als nicht zu reagieren weil
sie wissen dass sie Russland im
russischen Militär eine Atom macht sonst
alleine gegenüberstehen man kann das
loben dass man nicht auf Provokation
antwortet aber das heißt eigentlich
nichts anderes als dass die Ukraine
gezwungen wird peinliches Gebiet an
Russland an den Pimmel abzutreten
Philipp nun haben wir vorhin auch gerade
die Mitteilung bekommen von Olaf Scholz
das ist Genehmigungsverfahren für Nord
Stream 2 also die russische Gaspipeline
die das Gas nach Deutschland bringen
soll erstmal gestoppt hat das war auch
etwas dass der ukrainische Präsident
heute noch mal eindringlich gefordert
hat ist es aber in der Bevölkerung
überhaupt etwas dass die Leute überhaupt
auf dem Radar haben Nord Stream 2 sagt
das überhaupt irgendjemanden etwas
Philipp kannst du uns noch hören
jetzt höre ich dich wieder okay Philipp
ich hatte Dich gerade gefragt
ja ich hatte Dich gefragt Olaf Scholz
hatte also den das vorherige aus für
nordstream 2 verkündet das
Genehmigungsverfahren ist unterbrochen
worden jetzt das ist ja etwas das auch
ganz eindringlich der ukrainische
Präsident selenski heute noch mal
gefordert hatte ich frage mich ob das in
der Bevölkerung bei den Ukrainern
überhaupt ein Thema ist Nord Stream 2
kann damit jemand was anfangen weiß man
dass das ein wichtiges politisches
Druckmittel ist auch das jetzt zu einer
Sanktion eingesetzt worden ist und
befördert man das
ja die Ukraine ist ja selbst seit Jahren
im Gasstreit mit Russland Nord Stream 2
ist fast jedem Ukrainer absolut ein
Begriff und das das jetzt gestoppt wird
zumindest das Genehmigungsverfahren das
wird hier auch sicherlich sehr positiv
aufgenommen werden wenn man erwartet
dass er nicht gesagt seit Jahren schon
von Deutschland man hat seit Jahren
schon kein Verständnis dafür dass die
das Russland Krieg führt seit 2014 in
die Ukraine und Deutschland Nord Stream
2 einfach bislang weiterbauen liest und
das jetzt kurz wieder Abschluss steht
das heißt ja das Scholz dieses in diesen
Stoff des Genehmigungsverfahrens
angekündigt hat wird hier garantiert
sehr positiv aufgenommen
vielen Dank